So, hello I'm Erik Jorgensen from the University of Utah.
And today we have Drs. Tom Reese and John Heuser,
and we're going to be interviewing them and discussing
some of their seminal work that they did in the 1970s.
They were using electron microscopes, which you see in the background,
this is a device that uses electrons to image cells at a resolution
close to 1 nanometer. So this is the highest resolution microscope
possible. In the 1970s they performed experiments that allowed us
to understand neurotransmission, the fundamental behavior of a
cell during communication, and they're going to tell us about some of
their experiments that they performed then. So, what was the
experiment, what was known, what was not known,
and what was the experiment and what did it demonstrate?
We were interested in a little structure in the brain called a
synapse. And a synapse to me is about the most important
structure in the universe, because it's the way the nerve cells
communicate with each other. and it's these networks of
communication that allow us to think and remember. And
be conscious, and be who we are. So the synapse is sort of
the rockstar of biology because of its tremendous interest
and importance. I'd been interested in the synapse
when there was a great deal already known about it,
about how it worked electrically, it was known that it
released drugs, but nobody really had an intimate understanding
of how an actual individual synapse works. And that's what we wanted.
Yeah, and I was equally interested. And graduating from medical
school. And made a beeline for the laboratory where the original
work had been done that set the stage, where electrophysiologists
had demonstrated that the communication event at the synapse
involved release of little packages of chemical transmitters.
In little electrical blips that they could see. Now the man that did
that in his lab I was joining, Sir Bernard Katz, went on to get the Nobel
Prize after that. But his insight was profound and on top of that,
he'd written unbelievably beautiful papers that terribly impressed
me as a student. So made a beeline for that lab. He had
already looked at electron micrographs and seen that these
synapses on the inside were filled with tiny membranous
membrane vesicles, little spheres of membrane. And
he made the brilliant, but logical, interpretation that those
little spheres contained the packages of transmitters that he was
measuring electrically as little blips. And so he had the insight to
propose that the little electrical blips were being generated
by chemicals coming from those tiny packages. That was established,
I mean it was such a clear cut idea that it almost had to be
that way. And so my project when I entered that lab as a postdoc
in those days, you're basically assigned a project, was
to quote "prove it." Get an image of these little vesicles
popping on the surface of the nerve when I stimulate the
nerve. And during that postdoc, I didn't get it. But I had the
opportunity to join Tom Reese at the NIH immediately after that.
We reformulated the problem and came up with a whole new
approach to either proving or disproving that idea that
Katz had had.
So Tom, maybe you could tell us how it came to be that you
met John and how that led to a collaboration.
When John came to the lab, we decided to try a whole different
approach. As John pointed out, you usually went to a lab
as a postdoc and were assigned a project, but in his case,
he came to the lab and assigned me a project.
We were originally thinking about looking at the aftermath and trying
to interpret back to what might've happened. And that
was a good approach.
As it turned, yes. And the idea is if these little packages
are opening to discharge transmitter, and that's the mechanism
of communication, then during that moment of opening, they should be
able to capture material from outside the cell and carry it back in.
And it would be indirect proof that at least they had interacted with
the surface.
So what you demonstrated was that the membrane, the synaptic
vesicles were normally found in the synapse, in the
bouton, and that they had visited the surface, that's all you
could show and the problem was a question of time scale or
was there something missing?
There was the missing fact that we had nothing but
embalming fluid, and we were dropping these things into
embalming fluid every time. And life did not continue
in any kind of appropriate manner in that solution.
So we didn't capture it.
There's a missing piece here, and the next step of that,
was when we decided, well why don't we just stimulate
the nerve for various periods of time and then fix it
immediately or let it sit for a while and have a look.
So we did a series of different times and different amounts of
stimulation, and different time intervals for recovery. And
that turned out to be very informative, because when you
stimulated the nerve, the nerve ending where all the vesicles were,
it got quite a bit bigger as if the vesicles inside were being
added to the surface. And so that was a second piece of
evidence. And then if you waited a while after you stimulated
before you fixed, you went back to a perfectly normal looking
terminal. As if there was a cycle of activity and recovery.
And that cycle, now we know that that cycle involved
some recycling in the vesicle compartment. And I have to say, John,
it's always been very clear to me that the idea of vesicle recycling
was totally yours, okay?
I wish. -- No, I mean really!
At the time, I was astonished by this idea because it had never
occurred to me. And I'll take some credit later for some other stuff.
Well, it is true that the very first paper that we wrote on the
attempts in London to get it working, we didn't. But we got
this aftermath effect. We said maybe the vesicles are
dissolving and being reformed or --
You sort of had that in your head.
Or maybe it's merely recycling. Merely recycling.
Is the final sentence of my paper in London.
Merely. It became our career to pinning that down and
work it out.
So, back in 1973, one, when you published this, was it accepted at
that point? Was there anybody else who was doing these experiments
at the time? Tell me a little bit about what was going on
in 1973 when this paper came out.
73, there was a whole cadre of people doing this kind of work
all fascinated by the nervous system, all having electron
microscopy as their tool, they'd become experts at it. That was really
the heyday of electron microscopy. It was the opportunity
to see things for the first time at that resolution.
So everything was a gold mine and everything was fascinating and exciting.
People were going crazy. So there were a number of people
that were neurobiologists that also focused on the nerve terminal.
And the remarkable thing was that 2-3 groups, including groups
here at the Marine Biology Labs and in Europe, particularly in
Milan, were focusing on the exact same preparations as
us. And doing the exact same experiments. And we were
publishing in the exact same journals pictures that could've
been swapped from one paper to the other.
And just because of human nature, they were drawing completely
different conclusions about how to interpret those
micrographs. So there has never been peace in this field,
there's never been consensus. And we are still, to this day,
battling out the interpretation of what you see in an electron
micrograph. But the way we were thinking was indicative of
the way it's always been. We were -- why we left everybody
in the dust right then was because we were saying
how do you see it? How are we going to see that?
And so we do this, we do this, we put it on that
substrate, we look at it on this instrument, this and that, etc ...
We'd move instantly into the technology of it.
And getting the right image in the period. But you can't forget the rationale
for doing it at all, for working and developing this machine
was basically to capture this event of neurotransmission.
And the physiologists had taught us the event occurs on
1/1000 of a second. From when activity spreads into the nerve and
the nerve communicates with the next one by secreting these
little chemicals from synaptic vesicles. It takes only 1/1000
of a second for it to happen. And we needed to capture that event
on that same time scale. We needed to capture it on
its own, so that's why we went through on the effort to
develop the freezing machine further.
So maybe John, you could describe the instrument for
our viewers and all its glory and complications?
Well, I wish it were glorious and complicated.
But it couldn't be more trivial. It's a copper block, copper
chosen because it's very highly conductive metal, the most
conductive, particularly at those temperatures. So you have a heat
sink, the best heat sink you can think of or imagine, and
you want to apply the thing you want to study in the electron microscope,
in our case these little nerve terminals doing their secretory
event. Want to apply that prep to the copper block as abruptly
and precisely timed as possible. So we just plain plunked it down
on top of it. Just popped it into it. Touched it to the surface.
To the copper surface at 4 degrees Kelvin. And hook up all
the stimulating electrodes and develop methods of synchronizing them.
And how was it done? How did you time when you would
stimulate before it hit the copper block?
Simply had a magnet mounted right next to the sample,
which could be used by a little sensor that sensing magnets.
As the magnet passed the sensor, it said, "You're about to hit the
copper block!" And that stimulated the electrode that
fired the action potential in the nerve. So we could synchronize
that action potential arrived, the vesicle's discharged,
and the sample hit the copper block in 1/1000 of a second.
But you also had a problem with the sample freezing before
it ever hit the surface.
It got so close to the copper that it pre-froze before it would
get stimulated. But the real trick was and still is, and you need to use it,
the drug. The drug that augmented release, our physiology
friends who helped us work on it said, either between 1000
or 10,000 times, one nerve impulse would release 10,000 times
more vesicles than normal. If you make a nerve stimulate
-- release 10,000 times more than normal, it isn't going to want to do that
very often. It does it once. And it's shot. So we have to make sure
we don't pre-stimulate it as we're getting the whole experiment
ready.
So, you do the experiment, what do you see? Was there a eureka
moment where you were on the scope? And you said,
oh my god, this is it! We've seen the light!
This is the image we were looking for. I mean, can you
describe a little bit about that? Were you together, where did it happen?
As it happened, Tom wasn't there at the particular time that it happened.
He was back at NIH, and I was in San Francisco. But at that time,
I had Mike Denitz was a very fine physiologist who was doing
all this treatment with this magical drug that increased
things so much. And we had two young, even pre-docs,
maybe they had just gotten their postdoc, and they
wanted to learn some EM. So they were wandering around
my lab getting in the way underfoot, but one of them,
Lily Jan and her husband Yuh-Nung Jan, was the other
person wandering around. Both have gotten on to great careers.
But they, so they're sitting on the microscope, and they called me
into the microscope, and they said, John, I think we've got it.
I mean, look at that. And I came in and looked over their
shoulder and I said, no, no, no. That's a capillary.
You don't recognize there are whole bunch of little vesicles
attached to the surface of the capillary all the time.
That's part of transport of blood. Nothing to do with
nerves. You know, forget it. Looked a little harder, my god,
it is a nerve terminal! Look at all those openings. That really was a
eureka moment.
What was it you saw? What was it that you were actually
looking for that was the eureka?
Tom had explained how at that point were doing it by freeze
fracture. It's a method of looking at the surface of the
nerve by cracking open this frozen tissue. Particularly
nice, because after all, we'd started by freezing it.
So why not take advantage of that new technology.
So we're cracking all these nerves open. It's this tube,
so here's a long cylinder. And on that cylinder, dotting
all the way down are these small craters. Like craters on the moon.
And it's a very small jump to --
Remember the vesicles were originally lined up on this membrane.
Inside, and you couldn't see it from the outside.
You wouldn't have seen them at all. And so the fact that
you could now see openings, it meant that they had actually
exploded open under the surface of the -- just right before
the muscle hit the copper block and froze. So we'd captured
them in millisecond timescale. I don't think anybody had ever done
any anatomy structures of things at that time scale.
There was another story that emerged right after that, and that is
after the vesicle opened, we noticed that in the wall
-- in the membrane of the vesicle, there were various kinds of
structures and that as time -- you see it with this freezing,
you do a time experiment. You can stimulate at 10ms, 20ms,
30ms, so we noticed that as time passed, that the vesicle
was getting wider and wider open, and that some of these
particles inside, these structures inside, were coming out
and fusing into the surface membrane. And so that was now
the story where we measured all that. And that story,
we made a story out of that. So that was a third leg.
That was actually -- I enjoyed, actually, that part of it.
Well, it's a critical piece of the puzzle. Because if you have
these little packages of transmitter and they're capable of
fusing with the surface in 1/1000 of a second, activated
by calcium, what happens to them after that? And why
were we seeing all these strange changes at much longer
times? Well, that's when we really had fun with the freezing machine.
We were no longer just trying to capture the immediate moment
but the aftermath of the event. As Tom described it, we
could now do aftermath in really close coordination. We could do
looking just milliseconds later, and it's our conviction that
it's in the nature of the tiny membrane vesicles, something about
biophysics of membranes, that when that joins a larger membrane,
like the surface of the nerve terminal, it has no alternative
but it has to collapse. It has to flatten out, join that
membrane completely. Therefore, deposit all of its
contents and its whole nature.
Did this end the debate? So you showed the vesicle touches,
flattens out, and you basically, it's irreversible.
Absolutely. It ended the debate. Erik, you're baiting us because
you know perfectly well that our colleagues in Italy,
our colleagues at the MBL and such, did not accept
that this was happening. Yeah, they had to accept
that Katz was fundamentally right, that's how neurotransmission
occurs, by the fusion of these vesicles. But then is when interpretation
of electron micrographs end and how you did the experiment,
because they looked at the same micrographs of a vesicle
fused with a cell surface and concluded that that was it.
That that vesicle did that transiently, a little kiss. Kissed the
surface, let out transmitter, and simply reversed the process.
Now I was earlier describing to you that we thought
it's in the biophysics in membranes that they can't do that.
That if they've joined another bigger guy, they're going to merge
with it completely. And so there's a controversy that
is embedded in the literature, in scientific thinking
to date. And everybody asks about this still, are you
really correct that all of your aftermath stuff is really
true? Or should we believe the Italian group that it's just
a kiss? The vesicles are kissing and coming right back in
again and again, in exact momentary exposure and
enclosure. And that's the true biophysics.
And so you then did experiments that were over longer
and longer periods of time. And then you saw something
that said, well there is evidence that in fact these
vesicles are collapsing fully into the membrane.
Yes, the aftermath experiments of milliseconds.
Particles inside the membrane, the fusing into the membrane.
Particles being our marker, and membrane.
Particles are places where the membrane is impinged by
a transmembrane protein, and freeze fraction will show up as bumps.
And the bumps were diffusing out of the vesicle membrane
into the whole other membrane. Now it's not going to do that
in a kiss and run.
What is it that you know, you saw in your images that
convinced you that vesicles had to be recycled?
You know, the reason that I would've had a preliminary,
that I had a preliminary glimpse of that and said that maybe
merely recycling happened was because of the magic
clathrin coated vesicles that appeared in the nerve
terminal as a consequence of stimulation. And I had just
come from my undergraduate work, where I was exposed
to the father of electron microscopy, Keith Porter, and
his -- one of his, he had trained so many outstanding
people, but the person who was still present when I was in
college, was Tom Roth. And he had just discovered that
the mechanism for endocytosis, the mechanism of uptake of material
from the outside world in all cells is mediated by a vesicle
that has a coat, a beautiful cytoplasmic coat that actually is
polygonal. Like a geodesic dome. And you can see that
dome in the electron microscope. And so here I'm the young guy
in London, and I see these domes in nerve terminals as a
consequence of stimulation.
You'd seen those in London?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't know that.
And I said, oh my god, it's endocytosis!
And then it's also interesting that we managed to end a
total contentious situation with our Italian competitors
over that. Because they couldn't see these coated vesicles.
And why couldn't they see it and we did? Well, it was simply
that technique of embalming that we used. Our was a little bit
different than theirs. Ours had a little bit more heavy metal
than theirs. So, the coats looked a little more dramatic in our pictures
than in theirs. But that's the way that electron microscopists
butt horns and can enter total disagreement. Total contentions
over this kind of issue.
In the end, what I think solved the debate, are those freeze
etched images, where you see the clathrin coats.
This is absolutely clear that geodesic structures, absolutely
clear. Maybe you could tell us a little bit about the invention
of the freeze etch technique and how you used that to show
that there were clathrin coated vesicles?
That was a late chapter that arose from being able to
directly freeze things. Because if you freeze things out
of their natural juice, when you try to draw the water away
the contents of the juice collapse down on top of everything,
you can't see anything. So something we were able to
do was freeze directly and not using a fixative, which also
destroys things. We had a whole world of looking at the inside
of membranes. And that was invented in our summer neurobiology
course at Woods Hole by one of John's students.
They made a mistake on one of the machines and
John decided to have a look at it anyway, and that was one
of those eureka moments. All of a sudden, for the first time
we could actually look inside the cytoplasm. Not just look
at the membranes like we do with freeze fraction.
We could look inside the cytoplasm and you could see all
these wonderful coats. And John went on back to San Francisco
and began a decade of marvelous work looking at the
coated vesicle and coated vesicle endocytosis and cycling.
I think that's a good place to end it, but before we do,
I would like to ask if whether you guys have anything
like reflections, or memories or anything else you would like to add?
Thank you for being my friend all these years. In spite of
a few differences we have every now and then.
I can say exactly the same thing. Thank you for being my
friend. And muse, and a colleague, and it's just like.
I don't know. Hahahaha.